hello welcome everybody it's always fun
to have mid afternoon sessions in a hot
tent
my name is 3des Ramaswamy I lead the ads
and commerce teams at Google and here
with me is Polly but the product lead
for payments at Google and we're really
excited to be talking to you about all
the latest and greatest in Android faith
I want to start by addressing the
elephant in the room there are tons of
pays that are out there and all of you
want to know who's winning is there a
winner
but the sad answer is no not really
there is no winner legacy payments
methods like the credit card and cash
are still the dominant human methods
that are being used out there even the
most avid technology enthusiasts among
us is hesitant or scared to leave our
credit cards and cash behind and the
natural question is what's holding us
back you've thought a lot about this and
we think there are three big reasons for
this the first of course is a big one is
that all the mobile payment methods are
kind of limited some work for physical
contact list terminals some work with
all terminals you know sometimes it
works in app but not in it's the
unpredictability of whether your mobile
payment method is going to work that
makes you want to say nope I can't rely
on it 100% of the time we think the
second big reason is that you know a lot
of the payment schemes that are out
there are kind of on compelling you're
talking about an activity that all of us
do many times a week that we've done the
same way for many many years and so if
you're going to go ask humanity to
change the way that they think about
payments what what's the value add
they're kind of uncompelled and this is
something we really do want to address
as well and we actually think that the
uncoupling nature of the payment
solution comes about because most
payment solutions are kind of closed
they have a few key pieces of
functionality and that's it what makes
our smartphones great whether it's
Android or iOS is not just the operating
system you know we like aspects of off
our phones that come directly from
Google but the fact of the matter is
what we really love are our apps
it's a great functionality that comes on
it is the innovation the developers like
you have provided on the core platform
there is no comparable thing that's
going on in mobile payments we think
that's that's kind of a big blocker so
what do we want to do today we're going
to be talking to you about all the
things that we at Android Play and
Google are doing to make mobile payments
better for merchants and retailers for
financial institutions but most of all
for consumers like you and me beating
payments should work everywhere they're
expected to work they should work in a
simple and secure way and we think
mobile payment should be more like a
mobile payment passport than just a
mobile wallet and what you will hear
from us today is our efforts are really
making this happen so we want Android
pay therefore to be everywhere where you
and I expect it to be present so we're
gonna talk a lot about that starting
with how are we going to have Android
pay work on mobile web it works fine in
mobile apps we are also going to be
talking to you about how
I can hear some sound from behind can
others sharing so we are also going to
be talking to you about how Android pay
can work in other areas like public
transit you have a nifty demo coming up
or you know or there and also in things
like ATMs wherever you expect use
payment credentials we think Android pay
should be usable there and we'll show
you through all of this how we are
building a set of consistent and simple
experiences that all users will know and
love but one that will also come with
the security that is the promise of
mobile payments and finally we also want
to share with you what we are doing to
drive innovation in the ecosystem
whether it is with retailers or with
financial institutions like banks of
course the first part of being
everywhere is being geographically
everywhere so we are very pleased to
announce the expansion of Android pay
outside the US on to an international
location which is we went live in the UK
earlier today
while he was there last weekend he said
officiously running transaction to
design droid phone you know checking
things out for himself to make sure that
everything was fine we've worked we work
with top partners you see some of them
here HSBC lights Bank on to make sure
that there is a lot of acceptance for
Android pay and of course with lots of
apps and lots of physical locations and
this is only the beginning so I'm also
pleased to announce that we'll be
launching Android pay very soon over the
next few months in Singapore and in
Australia we want I know our ambition is
to be there everywhere Android is so
we're going to be launching in Singapore
and Australia so with many more
countries following soon after they are
all in the works so we are pleased with
how much we will be able to expand
Android pay through the world let's
switch gears now and talk a little bit
about what we've done with Android pay
in app inside apps we launched the
Android pay in-app API in December and
we've been working with a lot of app
developers to make Android pay be
accepted within their apps and we're
pleased with the results
top apps uber Airbnb gedcom instacart
and many others some of which are listed
here all support in-app payments with
Android pay and the first question
you're going to ask is like so what does
this make a difference we thought we'd
show that with one of the apps that
adopted Android pay fancy-fancy is a
really cool app in which you discover
card curated things this morning I was
browsing through stuff you know if you
can't tell I drink a lot of coffee and I
found this really neat espresso mug that
you could get from fancy that you know a
lot of other people have like fancy
adopted Android pay in app and saw some
pretty stunning results
for users that use Android pay within
fancy they found that their conversion
rate was twice that of other payment
methods I don't know how you folks think
about conversion rates but for something
like AdWords sign up in which a lot of
Google's fortune is dependent on a 1%
increase in conversion rate is cause for
major celebration and so getting a 2x
increase in conversion rate on what
turns out to be a substantial volume 20%
of Fancy's transactions flow through
Android pay is a big big deal for fancy
and is a big big deal for a lot of the
apps that have adopted Android pay we're
really pleased with the results that
we've seen with these and with other
apps
I'm not handed over to Polly he's gonna
show us a quick demo and also walk us
through some of the details of how
things are working yeah thank you sir
could we switch to ville fusion please
okay awesome so I'm gonna open up my
Nexus 5x device and I want to show you
Android pay working inside one of my
favorite apps Airbnb I love traveling
and I have a seven year old so we need
to make trips to Disneyland very very
frequently as some of you might know so
I'm gonna like try and book something
for a trip to Disneyland soon so let's
see here I think I'd saved a search here
for Disney and by the way this is
actually the production app so I want to
make sure that it's actually still
available so let's check for
availability selecting here it looks
like all of next week is available still
which is very nice tree that I hope you
don't mind this
he's a very good manager so the whole
week
so let me just save this and try to
instant book this and the cool thing
about this is really beautiful
experience right the one place where it
actually isn't all that great is
payments so if you go in and try to buy
something and book a reservation
typically it means you have to try and
like type in your credit card details
etc so we worked with Airbnb to make
this much better so I'm gonna try to add
a payment this is where I usually get a
screen that says enter your credit card
information right and if you have
Android pay setup on your device you
literally have to do nothing else just
pick Android pay that simple shows you
the chooser with Android pay and shows
you might discover card on there already
and all I have to do is confirm with my
fingerprint okay and and you can see
that Android pay is already selected
here and the next time I come in I don't
even have to do this right you
automatically can check out and you're
done so really really sweet experience I
personally love it okay so let me switch
back to the presentation if you don't
mind
so whenever I'm presenting which feed
are almost wondering where do I stand
right because dancing here seems like a
bad deal maybe I should stand here there
you go so what I wanted to share with
you is of course we've got this amazing
integration with Airbnb we've done the
same kind of integration with uber all
of these top apps right but how can
every single developer take advantage of
Android pay we wanted to make it really
really simple so we worked with a number
of top payment processors I think you
can just see this list everybody from
brain creators try to add yen we've got
cyber source everyone integrated into
Android pay
so that adding in Android pay if your
developer is really really simple in
fact if you're an integrator with
Braintree or stripe literally less than
ten lines of code that you can drop in
into your Android app and enable Android
pay for your users so that's very very
awesome we've also done more we've
opened up our API the Android pay in-app
API to all Android developers selling
physical goods or services so you can go
to this URL and start integrating right
away regardless of who your payment
processor is so it's very exciting for
us but this is not the whole story with
mobile check outs tell us more when I
hand it back to shredder Thank You Poli
it's really cool that in-app payments
I've been did we brush past ah I might
have actually just gone right past one
thing can you press I can I project back
on this yeah can we go back one slide
because I just want to show you one more
cool thing which we snuck in at the last
minute there are you and here's the
here's the cool part you must have heard
during the keynote earlier this morning
about Android instant apps what Android
instant apps are is this really cool
technology that lets you stream an app
to your phone
so don't worry about installing anything
you just stream the app by clicking on a
link and you get the full native
experience on your device just like
really awesome
now that full native experience wouldn't
be as awesome if you had to start typing
in all your credit card details to
complete your payment so what we did is
work with the Android team to enable
Android pay within instant apps so I'm
gonna share with you a little bit of
this experience maybe I'm gonna like
touch this and you'll see bnh photo I do
a search for a camera and you can see
that the link literally streams the bnh
photo app to my phone I can pick my
camera check out and then you get the
exact same experience I showed you
within an installed app right so
absolutely cool and gives you a complete
experience right in place and it's
streamed to your phone there's something
that we are very very excited about and
we expect more and more developers to
take advantage of this to reach more
users who've chosen not to install your
app but you can still get to them using
an instant app give them the same great
experience the user doesn't have to do
anything else
Android pay is set up on the device
it'll just work right so again something
that they very show up at your place by
drone instantly that would be actually
very cool so but we will talk about how
things can show up soon there you go so
Sridhar will tell us more about mobile
checkouts
so it's cool that we can solve the
problem of in act checkouts make it
easier make it streamline make it secure
but the fact of the matter is a lot of
us spent a lot of time on mobile web the
time spent is excuse more towards mobile
apps the fact of the matter is something
like half of all transactions happen on
mobile web
but mobile web does not have any of the
support that in apps have had it's a
different programming model and the
result is that you and I are stuck with
really long payment farms and it really
long
you know details forms that we have to
fill out very slowly on tiny keyboards
and it doesn't work that well they give
up pretty often conversion rates are
pretty low so we took a baby step last
year and were stunned by the results
that pizza made it's something that we
call you know chrome payments autofill
it's a it's a small idea take your
Google credentials your Google payment
credentials that you put into Android
pay that you have put into Google Play
and have it be available for forum Phila
on mobile web again for users that
actually used payment autofill you know
for checkout the merchants saw a 25%
increase in conversion rate again a
staggering number their wins come in
half and quarter and single digit
percentages and while this is cool
the larger problem still remains you
know you still have to fill out other
details go through language checkout
forms of course the dreaded user ID and
password I don't know about you but I
have a ton of password store - the
password manager on Chrome I have a
spreadsheet full of user IDs and
passwords that like I have to figure out
what - you know what to do with it just
keeps growing longer and we really need
to be able to do a whole lot better so
what if I were to tell you that you as a
merchant will be able to create an
experience for your consumer that's
gonna be simple and secure using
tokenized credentials and really make
these long checkout forms and the crazy
drop-offs a thing of the past and what
if you as a consumer also were able to
see all your mobile web transactions at
the same place along with your in-store
and in-app transactions the way you can
do with Android pay today we think
that'd be pretty
and so we are thrilled to announce
something we call payment request
working with the chrome team and
standardizing across all browsers to
really simplify mobile checkout it
provides in developers and you know and
retailers obviously the simple tools
that they need to create a great mobile
payment experience on mobile web and
this way users have a consistent
experience regardless of whether they
transact inside an app or on the mobile
web and while he's going to show us more
about how this works awesome if you can
switch to the wolf vision again this is
an API we're very excited about because
it's an open standardized API I'm going
to show how it works
within a website so open up a web site
in Chrome and turns out to be a little
store that we built for ourselves so we
can order branded gear and as you can
tell I love like wearing branded
t-shirts with Android pay on them
usually always gray always gray
unfortunately yes
I'm very bland in my taste of color so
I'm going to go in and shop for some
t-shirts as you can tell we have some
cool youtube t-shirts we also have just
plain Google t-shirts but because I'm
boring I'm just gonna pick Android pay
again it's gonna pick an Android pay
t-shirt I'm gonna add it to cart
okay and as I added to cart this is
usually like the portion of the
experience that you dread when you're on
a mobile website
and I've tried checking out before and
it literally is multiple pages filling
out everything from your billing address
shipping address including your credit
card information chrome water-filled
really helps you with that but what
payment request does is help you skip
all of this and get that same experience
that you saw within apps so what I'm
going to do now is actually show you the
checkout experience so I'm gonna hit
checkout did you notice how quickly that
came up so that's the full native
experience showing up in a website with
Android pay just working okay so I'm
gonna hit pay and again I have to
confirm with my fingerprint okay and you
can see my Bank of America MasterCard
there that I'm gonna use for my purchase
and it's just that simple okay I'm done
and notice I also got a notification
right away from the store which I can
open up and actually see within my Bank
of America okay right under the Bank of
America card in the Android pay app you
see all of the transactions that I've
made as well you see some of the
transactions are made
you should notice that Polly did the
same thing here that he did for the
in-app checkout he just unlocked the
phone no pins nothing else it just works
seamlessly which is what is cool about
this vision that we are driving yeah so
it's very exciting for us but of course
these API is always require one critical
thing for them to be successful and
that's all of you right and we wanted to
make sure that we have a set of partners
testing this API with us and testing the
experience with us so we could really
make it magical so I'm very pleased to
announce that we have a really awesome
set of partners already signed up to
beta test payment request and we also
have folks like Shopify and jet or Tom
adding in Android pay into this
experience as well so very very exciting
for us so with that I'm gonna switch
gears a little bit right and talk about
a critical use case for paying with your
phone and this is transit transit is
something that users in major cities
like London do at least twice a day and
sometimes many more times a day so if
there's ever anything that like both
meets and exceeds the toothbrush test if
you will its transit right so we're very
very excited to showcase the Android pay
experience for transit and we've done
that in partnership with one of the
leaders and contactless payments
Transport for London okay now if you
didn't know Transport for London
completes 13 million journeys daily for
Londoners across tube rail and bus so
it's absolutely huge volumes now one of
you could actually create an experience
that was just a little bit faster and
more convenient for all these Londoners
taking TFM and so we want to show you
what we worked on with the TfL team
and it's been an incredible partnership
but to demonstrate it I'm going to
direct your attention to the left there
do some TfL gates that we've actually
got from London it's absolutely cool
these are the real deal and what I'm
gonna demonstrate to you is an
experience is an experience that has the
exact same thing that Londoners are
using daily right now the only thing
we've done here that's a little bit more
custom is we've showcased an experience
that's going to be rolling out over the
next few months and by the end of the
year we should have it which shows you a
truly amazing experience in terms of how
the receipt show up with an Android pay
and want to demonstrate that to you as
well so we're very excited to do this
but without further ado I'm gonna enter
in through one station and then exit
through the other station and so you
should be able to see me entering
through the Paddington Station I think
this is so if you Vinnie if you can just
focus on the phone here so folks can see
it okay great
and so I'm gonna no need to open my app
nothing else literally all I need to do
tap and I've just paid with my lights
MasterCard absolutely incredible
and I think you saw how fast that
experience was and I personally
experienced this when I was in London so
I'm gonna tap again that's simple and it
truly is faster than the experience that
you actually can get using other forms
of payment so we're very excited about
this and I'm gonna show you the rest of
the experience on the wolfvision if we
don't mind switching so the first thing
that I'm gonna call your attention to is
what the receipt show up as so I'm gonna
go to my lights Bank MasterCard notice
that I actually got two notifications
here one for entering in the Paddington
Station and other for exiting in
Victoria okay really cool and I'm gonna
just go into one of those and it shows
you exactly where my journey was so
we're very very excited to be working
with TfL to bring this to Londoners
we're using Android pay that's the first
thing the second cool feature is today
when you forget to tap out unfortunately
what has to happen is and by the way
just to confirm what I mean tap out as
you enter your journey you have to tap
in as I just demonstrated what is you
exit you have to usually tap out
sometimes folks who are in a hurry
forget to tap out and they might get
charged the maximum amount for the day
now we've solved that problem for both
users and for TfL and you can see that
I've taken a bunch of rides while I was
there or the weekend
and I forgotten Tapout for one of them
on purpose and I got a notification from
Android pay and I don't know whether you
can see it oh it is a little white so
I'm gonna like try to tilt it a little
bit ah can you see that now perfect so I
have a notification that reminds me to
tap out and complete my journey so I can
avoid the maximum fare it's really
awesome for users and really awesome for
DFL as well so very very excited for
those of us that I've had a Hillary
Clinton moment in New York City subways
this is this is this is a welcome change
so I've set up Android pay right when we
launched last September and I've had my
Bank of America Visa card in Android pay
I'm a Bank of America customer and I've
had my Bank of America Visa debit card
in Android pay have used it for all
kinds of purchases the one thing I've
never been able to do with my Bank of
America Visa debit card is get cash at
an ATM but that's changed because we've
partnered with Bank of America and it
tell us more is michelle more of the
head of digital banking at bank of
america michelle thank you thank you
polly we're really excited to be here
today and excited to be a partner with
Android pay Bank of America is committed
to our clients to making their financial
lives simple easy and secure and to do
this that we've heard your feedback and
we have built with Android pay the
ability to withdraw cash at an ATM and
you can actually do it live today across
650 ATMs in the Silicon Valley in San
Francisco area
by the end of this month we'll be live
on 2400 ATMs and by the end of this year
5000 ATMs so why don't we take a walk
over to the ATM and see this in action
awesome look forward to seeing it so I
figured I would take out $20 and maybe
you can buy me one of these Android pay
shirts only cost like 9 bucks Michelle
so we'll send you to we'll have to
excellent thank you ok it's as easy as
holding the phone next to the reader
it's read the Android pay it is asking
me for my pin number like it normally
should for security purposes so I'll
enter in my pin $20 you buy me two
t-shirts oh good just what I always
wanted and here we go
live now
there you go set is that simple no more
reason to carry around your debit card
or your credit card what Michelle it's
only 16 bucks you can keep the change
well thank you awesome the pleasure
thank you so we're super excited thank
you for the partnership and look forward
to using this at an ATM really close by
and if you guys are in the San Francisco
area for a little bit longer take
advantage of this go try it out at a new
bank of america ATM near you okay thank
you thank you myself so you saw a couple
of the use cases for using Android pay
new use cases you saw of course the
journey on TfL and you saw the cash
withdrawals at the Bank of America
atm so now I want to talk to you about
one more feature that we're building in
partnership with all of our merchants
and that's the ability to save money as
well we already save you time and it's
convenient but what if we could save you
money too and to do that but I want to
showcase with you is the experience that
we've built with Walgreens it's
available to all our merchant partners
using an open API again but we're really
thrilled about what we've built with
Walgreens so let me grab one of these
phones here and we can go back to the
wolf fusion aha let me grab both the
phones
because I'm gonna show you two different
experiences and we are very excited
about it can we cut to the wolf vision
if you don't mind okay wonderful so we
have we have the phone up and before I
actually dive into the demo I just wanna
ask you a question how many of you have
signed up for a loyalty card but forgot
to use it when you're in the store it's
quite a few of us right and so we
figured we'd work with Walgreens to help
you save the car to Android pay so we
can automatically use it at checkout so
that we can remember it for you
and you never have to lose any more
points again now there's two ways to do
this the first way of course is if I'm
an existing member you remember I told
you I had a 7 year old kid means I'm a
frequent Walgreens customer ok go there
all the time and I've signed up for
balance rewards which is an amazing
loyalty program and so if you're an
existing user like me
Walgreens can just send you an email or
an SMS or even have a button on their
site that lets you just save it save the
balance rewards card to Android pay with
just one touch so let me just show it to
you within an email so got an email from
Walgreens
and they're giving me an offer to save
this balance award Carter Android pay
and I'm just going to do that by
touching it
and it's that simple okay balance robots
card safe to Android pay and it's
telling you that all I need to do to use
this is tap and I'm set okay very very
exciting but then what if you're not a
member already so we decided to build an
amazing experience for that as well so
I'm gonna show you an experience with an
Android pay okay
sorry let me get this up turns out that
I've paid at Walgreens okay with my Amex
card with an Android pay and I have a
receipt from Walgreens already in this
app open up the receipt it shows me an
amazingly helpful receipt which has the
map the exact location where I've made
this purchase and a personalized message
from Walgreens that lets me sign up for
the balance rewards card so I'm gonna
touch sign up here and notice that all
my information is already filled in okay
so no typing at all I'm going to
transfer and share this information to
Walgreens okay everything is filled in
again all I have to do is type in a
password which I'm going to do now
submit save
and I'm a new balance towards member so
very very cool and again it's as simple
as tapping on a Walgreens terminal in
order to use this balance rewards card
so we've made the experience really
really simple and it's available to all
merchants as well but let's go in and
try to complete this purchase here and
show you what the experience looks like
so we have here a terminal can we switch
this yeah we have your terminal this is
an actual Walgreens terminal okay and
we're gonna show you what it's like to
make a purchase of one of these really
nice like almonds okay turns out it
normally costs $5.99 then you can you
just focus in a little bit closer on it
so that maybe you can you can actually
see the charge okay so I think you
notice that rate so it's $5.99 except
that that's just a regular price if you
have a balance rewards card you get a
price break on this which is very cool
helps you save money okay so what I'm
gonna do is show you how easy it is to
use your balance rewards card with
Android pay so look at my phone again I
don't need to open the app this is the
consistent theme I don't have to open up
Android pay to use it etcetera I'm just
gonna tap I've transferred my balance
rewards card that's simple and I've got
a price break and the new price is 399
and to complete this purchase all I have
to do is tap again transfer my Amex and
the purchase is done okay
we're very excited about this experience
so look forward to seeing more merchants
integrate to this experience so that you
can engage your customers better and
your customers get to save money so with
that I want to hand over the suite our
thank you body these are some amazing
demos again of course we wanted to make
sure that we did something for small and
medium sized merchants as well so we've
worked with square to make available for
a limited time to qualified retailers a
free contactless reader as well as
discounted payment processing on all
Android pay transactions you want to
make sure that all merchants get benefit
then consumers use Android pay to pay I
want to touch on something really really
important is the last portion of our
talk but it's super critical it hits
many of the points that I talked about
earlier it's clear that financial
institutions the ones that we have over
credit debit all these relationships
will need to play an active role in
moving the mobile payment ecosystem
forward and when we envision Android pay
we created a api's that these banks
could use to bring the payment
experience right within their are why is
this a big deal because there's a lot of
detail to implementing a great payment
experience and they could integrate it
right into their app saving themselves a
lot of implementation headaches security
headaches and of course time which is
the most important currency and they do
that then they're free to innovate on
what else they offer their consumers
these banks are often the ones that know
us best they're the ones that are
observed
our transactions you know they're the
ones that we have a relationships if we
think this will drive a lot of
innovation in how mobile payments are
brought out to consumers so we're very
pleased that a number of banks both in
the US and abroad are working with us to
integrate Android pay directly into the
era we think this will drive more
innovation and provide more flexibility
for consumers we think of this as a
win-win for Android Android pay and far
you know these banks and of course
consumers as well and with that now I
want to thank all of you our developer
partners in bringing this Android story
forward without us working together
there's not going to be a lot of
innovation and so we really look to
working with you to improve the way
mobile payments work so and for us to
get past the rich pay is doing what and
more to mobile payments just work in a
way that is expected and convenient for
all of us so thanks to all of you for
helping us realize this vision of
Android pay being everywhere in mobile
apps in physical stores in mobile web as
well so Polly and I have barely touched
on the surface of topics that can
literally take days of discussion you're
going to be having lots of breakout
sessions over the next two days and I
think one right after left right here
and so please add in those please ask us
lots of questions that we folks from the
payments team in all of these all of
these breakout sessions we look forward
to talking with you and really helping
bring this vision of Android pay to the
larger room and with that thank you all
for coming